[Music]
looks normal to me when did this start
happen since Helen got the job I assume
she knows are you kidding I can't tell
her about this not while she's doing
hero work I've got to succeed so she can
succeed so we can't succeed it Bob
I get it when was the last time you
slept keeps track of that besides he's a
baby I can handle it I got this handle
so you're good then you got everything
under control
right that is freaky did you wash your
hands with soap did you dry them all
vegetables all vegetable I did so are we
going to talk about it what the elephant
in the room
what elephant
mom's new job
it's time to make some wrong things
right help me bring supers back into the
sunlight we need to change people's
perceptions about superheroes and
Elastigirl is our best play better than
me I watch the kids no problem do it dad
they want us to do it I don't know that
way why would they change math math is
math hello hey honey
everything's great
[Music]
he's in excellent health cooking that is
freaky you know it's crazy right to help
my family I gotta leave it to fix the
law I gotta break it you got to destroy
kids can have that choice thank you
young man
combustion imminent what does that mean
it means fire Robert
[Music]
the screen slacker interrupts this
program for an important announced that
it might get weird I'll be there
[Music]